[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia, Developer
Advocate on the Google Cloud
team.
And today, I'm going to show
you how to use Vertex AI
and help a friend get into yoga.
We are building a yoga
pose classification model.
Let's get started.
First thing we need is the data.
For this step, my
friend Sara and I
collected a bunch of
images from a yoga practice
and uploaded them into
the managed data sets.
As you see here, the images
are labeled in five categories.
I can even upload unlabeled
images and label them.
We can analyze our
data set to see
that we have enough
examples of each categories.
Now, we are ready
to train our model.
In here, I'm selecting
AutoML for training method.
You can also train a model
to deploy on the Edge
or on Premise, or use custom
training if you're writing
your own custom model code.
Now, we define our model.
AutoML automatically
splits the data
into training,
validation, and test.
But we can change
it if you want to.
In Compute and pricing, we get
to select how many node hours
we want to train the model.
At this point, we wait
for the model to train.
Once it is trained, we
see it in the Model tab
and can evaluate the model.
We can see our model's
average precision.
It ranges from 0 to 1, where a
higher value indicates a higher
quality model.
We can see that the
confusion matrix
helps us understand where our
model is confusing two results.
Now that we have
evaluated our model,
it's time to deploy
it to an endpoint.
We can split traffic
between two models deployed
on the same endpoint if needed.
Allocate the number of nodes
needed for this endpoint.
Depending on where
your users are,
select a region to
deploy your endpoint.
And that's it.
Hit Deploy, and we
have an endpoint.
Now, we can test our
endpoint and the model
by uploading an image.
And yay, it works.
You can also make
predictions using the SDK.
If this has peaked your
interest in Vertex AI
and you want to learn more,
head over to the documentation
linked on screen.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]